hello everyone
bonjour tour
i am so honored to
be joining you here today at cfb trenton
which is on the traditional territory of
the mohawks of the bay of quinte
also known
as kanye kahaka community of the taienta
naga
this is my first visit to this community
since being appointed as the minister of
national defense
and i truly appreciate
the
opportunity
to learn more about how the canadian
armed forces members stationed here
are keeping canada and north america
safe
and helping to uphold our collective
security including the work that they
are doing in response to the crisis in
ukraine
since putin launched his full-scale
invasion of ukraine two months ago
cfp trenton has served
as the departure point for much of the
military aid that canada has been
providing to ukraine
to fight and win this war
mal grey
to help address the growing crisis at
the border between poland and ukraine
i am announcing today the deployment of
up to 150
canadian armed forces personnel
with approximately 100 personnel in the
immediate term who will assist poland's
efforts to support
and care
for ukrainians
fleeing violence
the majority
will
come from edmonton and kingston
and through here in trenton in the
coming days
[Music]
now over the next few months our
military will provide support across
three lines of effort
first we will be deploying armed forces
members to reception centers
across poland to assist with the
immediate care and processing of
ukrainian refugees
this is the largest component of our
deployment to poland
our people will provide general support
spiritual services and limited medical
care enabled by ukrainian speaking caf
personnel
second
we will deploy a number of members in
support of a polish-led humanitarian
assistance task force
we will work with military members and
other government representatives from
canada
from poland and from other allies to
synchronize efforts
from more than 100 multinational
humanitarian agencies to ensure
that ukrainians fleeing the war
receive the best support possible
and third we will assist immigration
refugees and citizenship canada by
acting as a liaison
with the polish defense forces as ircc
works so that thousands more ukrainians
can continue to resettle in this country
contribute
these efforts are being carried out as
part of operation reassurance
canada's contribution to nato's
assurance and deterrence measures in
central and eastern europe which we
recently expanded and extended over the
past few months
through operation reassurance and the
international response to the war in
ukraine
we have shown how strong and effective
we can be
when we work on a united front
it is more important than ever for
canada to stay engaged with our allies
and partners
and through budget 2022 we have
committed another half billion dollars
worth of military aid
to ukraine and that is on top of the 110
million dollars that we have pledged
thus far so that our ukrainian friends
have the equipment that they need to
keep fighting this war and
[Music]
as this crisis continues to unfold we
will keep working with the international
community to respond effectively
and we will keep ensuring that our
military has what it needs to protect
and to defend canada
to this end
through budget 2022 we announced more
than eight billion dollars in new
funding for our military and the
communications security establishment
we will also undertake a review of
defense policy to ensure that we remain
ready
to meet current and emerging threats
here at home and around the world
in many ways the world is a much less
safe place than it was two years ago
and certainly two months ago
and we must take stock and take action
in order to remain a valuable reliable
ally and partner for decades to come
to conclude i cannot imagine
the heartbreak felt by millions of
ukrainians who are forced to flee
putin's shelling and bombing
the heartbreak of thousands of canadians
with loved ones who remain in ukraine
now
but in the face of unspeakable acts of
violence carried out against innocent
civilians
and of despicable acts
and attacks on schools apartment
buildings train stations in kiev kharkiv
boucha
and of tragic desperation
canadians and our canadian armed forces
will continue to step up
and offer a safe haven and to welcome
with open arms the people of ukraine
our friends
thank you merci nige
i can answer questions if you like thank
you minister we'll now start the
question and answer period from
journalists right here merci beaucoup
uh journalists will have one question
and one follow-up and uh please state
your name and outlet
david aiken global news good morning
minister
um
i wonder if you could maybe speak to the
genesis of this particular mission um
whether it was through a request from
polish authorities i know the prime
minister has spoken quite often to uh
ukraine's prime minister ukraine's
president um did we offer can you give
us a sense of how this mission sort of
came together
well i'll start with the basic point
that canada stands with ukraine we've
been one of the lead countries within
nato in terms of support for ukraine and
we will continue to provide
comprehensive humanitarian
economic and military aid in terms of
today's announcement
the prime minister and i have been in
close touch with our counterparts in
poland as well as with the nato alliance
writ large and we are committing these
additional
resources under operation reassurance
which is uh our mission in support of
nato's eastern flank
thank you
there are some reports i think from the
csc that uh the russians part of the
russian disinformation campaign is to
generate images that seemed to purport
to show canadian forces actively engaged
in combat
in
i guess in ukraine in the theater
thinking about that i wonder if you can
comment does that raise the threat level
for some of the folks who are about to
deploy or for our folks already overseas
right now has has the threat level for
our forces changed i know you can't get
into too much detail on that can you
speak to that in general terms
from the very beginning
we have been
unified as a nato alliance that we will
do whatever is needed to ensure
that we are supporting ukraine and also
that we are making our respective
contributions on the ground to the nato
alliance
and this mission in poland is part of
that commitment
and we
very much are aware of article 5 of the
washington treaty
that an attack on one is an attack on
all
the threat level of course is
one that we are constantly watching and
we will continue to do so
at the current time we are confident
that this is a mission that should be
undertaken in the interests of
humanitarian aid in the interests of
aiding our polish allies and in the
interests of the nato alliance writ
large
as refugees
are fleeing ukraine and this
humanitarian support is needed in poland
immediately
thank you merci next question
hi minister tom perry with cbc you
mentioned that there's going to be
ukrainian speakers going on this mission
i'm wondering if you can tell me um how
many
of
the people we're sending will be
ukrainian speakers what they'll be doing
and as a second part of this question
you mentioned in the budget of the
budget talked about 500 million dollars
in further military aid for ukraine
uh when do you think you're going to be
getting some more detail on that and if
i can get you to answer in english and
french that'd be great
thank you so much for the question
on the first question regarding
ukrainian speakers i will
turn
uh to
ryan uh but
on the second question i have to admit i
couldn't quite hear you um can you speak
sure it was about the about the 500
million dollars in uh weapons aid for
ukraine announced in the budget when can
we expect further details about what
that's going to be
okay i'll start with that and then i'll
hand over the mic on ukrainian speakers
in the
forces
the budget which came down just a week
ago today committed 500 million dollars
in military aid to ukraine that is on
top of the 110 million dollars of aid
already that our government has
committed
this age should be conceived in
various categories which is how i think
about it the first category is calf
inventory which we have largely drawn
upon for the existing aid that we are
sending the second category is
procurements from suppliers we are
actively engaged with
a number of suppliers regarding
additional procurements and i will have
more information to say about the
those discussions soon
i will say that they follow the type of
negotiation and contract that we entered
into for the cameras for drones that we
announced
a few weeks ago
we were asked by ukraine directly to
supply cameras for these drones within
days we had a contract in place and
cameras
sent over to ukraine that is the type of
effort we will continue to do under that
second category and the third category
of aid that we are examining is in
conjunction with our allies
working together collaboratively with
our allies in terms of possibly pooling
our aid so that we can send over aid as
efficiently
as possible as a collective and in that
vein we did have a donors conference
with which was hosted by the united
kingdom recently and
we are very much aligned as
nato allies to ensure that we are
working efficiently as possible given
the urgency of the situation and the
fact that uh minister resnickoff is in
touch with me
almost daily in terms of what is needed
for ukraine and that's what i'm working
to fulfill in terms of the list can i
get you just repeat that briefly in
french
on the uh just
convo
deja
[Music]
thank you minister
so i understand the question correctly
you're asking how many ukrainian
speakers we'll be sending uh over to
theater is that correct sir exactly how
many and i guess what role are they
going to be playing in the operation so
i will answer the question by saying
that we have a very diverse force in the
canadian armed forces and with that
comes many different people with
proficiency in different languages as
far as the number of folks that we are
sending over to the operation i can't
answer that for you because i don't have
those details in front of me and as far
as how they will be employed i think
when we send anyone to these different
operations in different locations around
the world we try to ensure that they
have the linguistic capability such that
we can integrate better with the folks
who are trying to help thank you
and minister just as a follow-up then
a review into the
rapid release of former navy commander
danny croucher found
the military violated its own policy how
did that happen and how will you prevent
it from happening again
sorry
every single day um i continue to work
with general air and leaders across the
canadian armed forces to build a
military where everyone feels safe
protected and respected and this is
crucial to the canadian armed forces
mission to serve and protect canadians
i am aware
that there is
a
situation
in terms of our policy
where members are alleged to have
violated professional standards
but are legally entitled to a release
and i believe that is the situation that
you are raising in your question
i will say
that our processes need to be better
aligned so that victims and survivors do
feel safe respected and protected at
work
we have the cpcc
and jenny calhoun that is working on a
number of initiatives
to ensure that members feel safe
protected and respected at work we are
also awaiting the report
of madame arbor
that hopefully will speak to this issue
thank you
can i just get you to repeat that in
french please
so
mercy
thank you merci do you have any other
questions
all right seeing none this concludes
today's press conference